je trouve sur sub nautique à 3
aujourd'hui on va essayer de construire
le sous marin pour ça c'est extrêmement
simple nous avons besoin j'ai pris une
photo sur mon téléphone comme les vrais
scientifiques il nous faut cinq lingots
de plaques d'acier sa nouvelle émaillé
que nous avons de lubrifiants que nous
avons et un kiki je suis un scientifique
dyslexique et un kit de câblage avancées
que nous avons en gros ils demandent
juste les cinq lingots de plaques
d'acier et pour faire un go-fast acier
il faut à l'ago titane scène en a c'est
qu'on est beau mais il faut aussi un
lithium et le lithium ou le tronc vous
bat dix mois il est vrai un scientifique
sur en scène et en tant que bons
scientifiques je me suis renseigné et
pour trouver du lithium il faut aller
dans une zone très spécifique qui est
vraiment ultra profondes
du coup j'ai construit une armée de
tuyaux on fait avec ce qu'on a et j'ai
aussi quatre piles pour pouvoir
recharger l'énergie du tout qui nous
fait avancer vite elles fonctionnent à
piles [ __ ] ce comme la manette de xbox
a fait chier quoi c'est pour vos
microsoft en gros le lithium si vous
voulez ça ressemble awkward c'est comme
ça mais en bleu et en un peu plus petit
donc en gros le mec suis un peu le lot
roja et ensuite il faut longer la zone
de radioactivité j'espère tellement
qu'on va trouver [ __ ] je pense qu'on
n'est pas trop mal là actuellement on
est bien parallèles aux navires par quoi
il ya des bruits de mons de ouf la
mecque j'ai parce que y'a en bas mais
[ __ ] on va se chie dessus ça doit être
par là à temps non c'est pas du lithium
ça non c'est une vieille plan de merde
elle a feinté je sais que c'est pas là
puisque j'ai lu que c'était vers à la
forêt aux champignons et la foire aux
champignons landes se noue allez c'est
parti
as
respirons un peu tu as non relié à la
surface mais non mais non mais c'est un
sketch mon gars là c'est bon il est
relié ouais c'est bon [ __ ] oh là là
haut il y avait il y avait cet animal là
dans la vidéo que j'ai vu avant le
lithium
donc à mon avis on n'est pas loin on va
prendre de l'air un peu tu honores liés
à la surface mais tu rigoles
ah c'est bon ça marche ou c'est quoi ça
frau ya des créatures abus c'est à cette
profondeur allez juste un lithium pour
nous donner ou non à un mec au rayon
d'un 2e ou d'un deuxième j'étais
tellement persuadé que ça allait fort et
que tout ce qu'on entreprend dans ces
[ __ ] de vidéo mais un mail ou
tumultueux loup le tuyau au nom au nom
j'ai fait de la merde on va mourir noyé
j'ai oublié de rester pas loin du tuyau
et voit la super à l'appliquer à tout
recommencer
c'est pas grave on va trouver lithium on
est bien vous en faites pas voyage fait
claquer des doigts et on sera devant et
lithium et voila voila je vous avais
promis des effets spéciaux dignes des
plus grands films hollywoodiens
on est déjà à 3 2 lithium l'aller on
redescend pour un lithium et on est bon
[ __ ] je suis tellement heureux que mon
plan a fonctionné bordel on est des
vrais scientifiques diplôme du
scientifique la regarde et on en a deux
ici on fait du rav au cas où on est bon
et on rentre tout 60 vers la base sur un
superbe lever de soleil magnifique vers
l'itunes servait à rien donc je me suis
vraiment fait chier pendant 20 minutes à
faire des vieux tuyaux en caoutchouc
pour les pauses et crever les moussons
de leur jalousie bien tourner dans notre
sous marins ça rime pas faux courts
passe à la base pour choper les
matériaux jamie en stock dans cette
caisse là logiquement on a tous les
matériaux c'est pas celle là c'est celle
là voilà mon gamin s'il va nous manquer
de lingots de titane en fait je me
trompais regardez regardez un homme
heureux
lingots de plaques d'acier aux lingots
de passer x 2 c'est une belle journée 1
c'est une belle journée non mais on peut
le dire on peut dire ah [ __ ] le lâche
quoi punch dans mon inventaire c'est ça
qui me tape là mais d'une crevette tu
fais quoi toi et je vais te défoncer
voilà on en parle plus et les deux
rôdeurs pour info en fait on les trouve
par terre voilà puis en fait ils mangent
des débris métalliques du coup il perd
lors dans ces gros cons hausse à sa
chance et de l'or ça olalalala et
et lingots de titane et lingots de place
à ces veuves de créatures attend génial
ou les bancs tout de suite j'ai pas à
quoi ça va servir à l'enlèvement tout de
suite mon gars allez allez la [ __ ] on
touche au but il manque juste un peu de
titane s'il vous plaît oh oui boîte
c'est une créature ça mais vous vous
foutez de ma gueule mais c'est plus
grand que ma base soit 1000 ça plus avec
ça surtout grenier depuis tout à l'heure
en plus il est pas content le pense qu
il prouve qu'il veut quand il veut mais
n'est pas content le dernier la 2e place
à ciel et j'en à tout ça y est en route
vers la construction de notre nouvel
habitacle
bonjour je suis là après miller de farm
je veux kraft et le attendant c'est le
sim au dessus le cyclope ce qu'on fait
dix morts sous marin à usage industriel
et l'autre c'est un submersible pour une
personne à temps on fait le cyclope sas
était mille fois de plus simple de faire
un si beau sans plus
c'est parti pour les six clubs
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
wahou
ils n'ont pas ce qu'ils ressentent ou
bande à a fait un simple efficace
porte-voix aux chevaux de trait c'est le
mien c'est l'eau bien aux augustins par
contre j'aurais dû le crafter en lieu
beaucoup plus profond j'ai fait de la
merde mais c'est pas grave mais que
c'est génial j'ai vu ça oh la la ville
immense moi je crois que c'était le
petit truc on n'y met pas du tout il ya
plein de sales quoi batteries batteries
batteries dans mes mecs mais je suis
comme un gamin
c'est noël il ya les commandes l'art
piloter sous marins non non non et je
suis heureux et on vient de le créer les
jay chou et j'ai envie de chialer chez
moi avec cette petite cuillère comme ça
[Musique]
après vingt minutes de farming nous
avons quoi construire une nouvelle
baisse véhicule mobile qu'on va vraiment
mettre beaucoup plus profond d'un hop ni
quelle est cette fois on construit sous
marins mais ça foire pas la logique mont
nébo voilà ça y est ah on est dedans tu
t'es bien droit cette fois c'est pas de
travers comme tout à l'heure et de clash
peut le conduire mais non mais non
mais mon gars mais c'est chez mais je
suis en total kif
alors les rondeurs vous êtes tous au wap
eu trop d un
c'est quoi ça les choses bizarres qui
apparaissent on s'enfonce en fosse par
contre je stresse n'y a pas un savez un
truc pour fabriquer des choses quoi ah
si je sais ok faut utiliser ça hop on va
le mettre juste ici à temps il ya du
bruit là qu'est ce qui se passe
il ya une créature qui route c'est ça
vous les entendez ou pas ouais mais
c'est 50 sites us avec j attends moi je
me casse
on va se décaler parce que le kraken au
dessus nous il va nous défoncer il fait
des altos il amusé est-ce qu'on peut pas
lui fausser deux gros tas de merde
chjama tard il fait rien du tout le
compte du coup on va aller dans la zone
fuites radioactives et on va checker ce
que yao roja on est là dans quelques
instants en plus on avait une
combinaison antiradiations ne crains pas
du tout c'est obligé qu'il ya un truc de
malade là tout un genre à un minerai le
trail pari de construire à chez pas bon
c'est quoi ça attends je suis patrick
notre vaisseau le tiennent quand même à
eau à temps on va on voit ce vaisseau va
lui mettre un coup de vaisseau s'y
adapte en brèche dans la coque détecté à
temps mais c'est quoi le délire des
brèches l'afojel réparé au oui regardez
mais non une fois il me faut un soudeur
j'en ai pas je tire abandonner le navire
je me dire je me tire ça lui est mon
frère tu as cru tt qui dans l'océan toi
on va être juste il ya pas de sendou
après cette catastrophe j'espère ça vous
a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aller
mais comme d'habitude je suis content
parce qu'on a construit le plus gros
vaisseaux du jeu enfin je crois que
c'est le plus gros est la prochaine
rencontre sera le plus petit
individuelles qui va plus vite ils se
déplacent plus facilement écouter on se
retrouve bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo
je pense que reims nautique à 4 s'il ya
encore quelque chose à faire maintenant
on a construit le plus gros truc donc
jeu on est trop fort et trop modeste
alors sortez dans une prochaine vidéo
merci pour tous les commentaires que
vous avez posté sur les vidéos super
nautica ça m'a beaucoup aidé puis à
bientôt une prochaine vidéo au jazz ou
moins en pis
[Musique]